Welcome to Engineering
for a Reliability with Google Cloud.
Hi! I am Riccardo,
Developer Advocate in Google.
I work with customers
on reliability topics.
In this episode, we're going to explore
the Art of SLOs,
and why it may be useful
for your organization.
♪ [music] ♪
Wait, what is Art of SLOs?
It's a workshop that will teach you
how to choose SLIs and SLOs
for your workloads.
But first, what are SLIs and SLOs?
Well, you might've heard about
or even read the SRE books
available for free on sre.google/books.
Here you'll find plenty of information
on how Google operates reliable services.
One of the main takeaways of that
is reliability is a key feature
of your service,
and that you should measure it
and set targets for it.
At this point, you might ask yourself,
"Okay, but how do I choose
what reliability target metrics
and thresholds
are appropriate for my application?
I mean, you don't want to be paged
every time a VM reboots, right?
You only want to be paged
when you believe that your service
is not meeting your user expectations.
To get there, you need a way
to measure your service's ability
to keep your users happy,
in a way to set targets
for what's reliable enough.
Let's delve into it.
An SLI is a measure
of how reliable a service is.
For example, if your service
provides an API,
you may choose Latency or Availability,
but for a Data Processing pipeline,
you may look more
at data Freshness or Throughput.
An SLO describes when a service
is reliable enough to meet user needs.
An Error Budget is just a complement
of the SLO,
so if your team chooses that 99%
is Reliability target,
the Error Budget will be 1%.
That 1% is the acceptable level
of unreliability.
You allocate the Error Budget
to maximize your development velocity,
while maintaining the reliability
of your service.
Okay, but what is the right target,
what is enough?
Setting the right SLO in practice
is really hard.
This is why we have created
a workshop to teach you.
We came up with a sample online game,
played by millions
of users all over the world
dividing to Vampire clans.
We also have a Leader Board
to check if you are in the top ten.
There are plenty
of business Critical User Journeys:
Log in, Monetization, Battles, Profiles,
Leader Board Generation.
All things your players care about.
And how do you use this?
Each Journey is a pragmatic
and self-contained exercise
where you will need to find
what SLI you care about.
Let's say-- latency.
Okay, but latency
between which two points in time?
You need to break your journey down
to the scope that you believe
is most important for your user.
Your team initially will disagree
on which is more important,
and the discussion that will come up,
until you reach consensus,
is crucial.
As you likely trade-off
between business requirements
and engineering constraints.
And now, where do we measure it?
At the Load Balancer or on the client app?
Your team will build up the muscles
to determine the right SLOs
fo your journey.
And usually, after two
or three iterations,
your team will get a lot better at this.
"Sounds good, Riccardo,"
you might be thinking,
"but how much does it cost?"
Nothing. It's all freely available
under Creative Commons license.
You have slides and docs
for the facilitator
who will moderate that workshop,
and a Participant Handbook
that you can share with the team.
Further, the workshop has materials
like Retrospective Exercise
to refine an existing SLO.
I hope I made you curious now.
Feel free to check it out,
and let us know what you think.
[ringing]
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, folks. I've just been paged.
We're burning Error Budget
for our latency SLO
in the European region.
I need to fix this ASAP to ensure
that we stay within our SLO.
I knew I shouldn't have shot this video
while on call.
Hah, wish me luck!
♪ [outro music] ♪